[Vex on P.A.]
Stereo Campari's
700 Corrupt Cops
will begin momentarily.
But first, here's the rockabilly
music stylings
of Buster Brown's
Midnight Moonshine
and The Texas
"Hold 'Em" Boys!
[cheers and applause]
♪ Well ♪
♪ We're gonna cop
this town down tonight ♪
♪ We're gonna cop this town
down tonight ♪
♪ We're gonna cop
this town down tonight ♪
♪ We're gonna cop this town,
make it feel all right ♪
♪ Cop, Cop, Coppity Cop ♪
♪ We're gonna Cop
this town tonight! ♪
♪ Oh oh whoo ♪
[off-key]
♪ ♪
Guitar!
Play those chords!
♪ ♪
Never again.
♪ Yeah, when I say cop,
you say cop ♪
- ♪ Cop ♪
- ♪ Cop! ♪
♪ Yeah, when I say cop,
you say cop ♪
- ♪ Cop ♪
- ♪ Cop! ♪
♪ Cop to your left,
cop to your right ♪
♪ Cop all the way,
cop all night ♪
♪ Cop, cop, coppity cop ♪
♪ We're gonna cop this
town tonight ♪
[cheers and applause]
Thank you.
Thanks, everybody.